foreign
beautiful snowy white day look at this
beautiful
to tell you and to thank you because
this is my first day that I've been able
to spend
a day doing the side Trek videos I have
actually been able to go down to four
days a week in my day job
to concentrate at least one day a week
on the side Trek channels and that is
down to you guys supporting us and for
watching all of our stupid little videos
we started this channel 18 months ago
now and we're pushing on 20 000
subscribers and that is absolutely
incredible thank you so so much
so what am I doing on my first proper
day at work for the Sidetrack Channel
well
I'm going to record three maybe four
videos I don't have to edit them I then
have to write a story for patreon and
record a related podcast episode
I better get on with it but thank you
again and here's to the next 20 000
subscribers and the day that I can do a
video when I get into three days a week
in my day job
that's the dream
thanks guys see you soon and uh if it's
snowing where you are be careful it's a
bit treacherous
stay safe guys bye